et c'est donc un week-end de tensions
qui se prépare avec la possibilité que
les antilles masque se greffent au
mouvement c'est notre question ce soir
gilet jaune policiers l'affrontement est
il inévitable c'est l'objet de notre
face à face et pas de dingle pour en
débattre
nous sommes en direct avec bruno
bartocetti secrétaire national délégué
zone sud unité sgp police et puis dans
quelques instants c'est linda bigot un
gilet jaune qui va nous rejoindre
on dirait que par téléphone on a un
petit soucis de connexion on va
commencer avec vous au bruno bartocetti
est ce que vous craignez justement de
grosses tensions alors que l'on sait
notamment dans la capitale que plusieurs
rues et bien sont interdites à la
manifestation ce samedi en soirée merci
de m'avoir way les manifestations des
gilets jaunes vont entraîner peut-être
dix vingt trente mille personnes partout
en france mais on pouvait gérer deux
millions de personnes dans les rues 1
995 pourparlers de la dernière
manifestation
mais là dans un contexte comme 95 par
exemple que vous aviez un 1,80
sécuritaire autour d'eux des mouvements
des manifestations mais là quand on
parle aujourd'hui d'un gilet jaune et
avec tout le respect que l'on boit ou
gilet jaune
on condamne bien évidemment ce qui est
un filtre ce mouvement de gilet jaune
pour en faire un mouvement de violence
urbaine
donc bien sûr concret ce mouvement là
mais une sauront paris nous serons
préparés pour empêcher de voir évoluer
ces violences urbaines comme le zoo
évolué depuis
depuis quelques quelques années vous
savez notre organisation ses peines au
début le mouvement déchiré jaune et
gilet jaune aujourd'hui n'existe pas au
monde il existe de plus pourront venir
exprès au tout début de rassemblement
aux gens
dites vous êtes paré voilà pour ces
violences urbaines les consignes
ont-elles changé quelles sont-elles
aujourd'hui de la part des autorités
envers la police
de toute façon elles seront adaptées aux
situations on ne peut pas parler de
déchargement maintenant les forces de
l'ordre sauront seront en nombre 41
autres unités de forces mobiles plus et
les compagnies de police de paris puis
partout en france on aime on est préparé
à ceux-ci de toute façon ne fléchira pas
qu'on joue petit vent les violences
urbaines et on s'adaptera aux situations
il est hors de question d'accepter
aujourd'hui c'est à dire notre
république est d'ailleurs j'espère qu'on
va y revenir puisque la violence elle
commence dans les mots et les maux qui
ont été tenus par c'est donc je ne sais
pas si mal en tête mais les manques tu
as été tenus par par jérôme rodriguez
sont une insulte pour la république s'il
se revendique leader des gilet jaune
je regrette mais dgd jonasson ne l'ont
pas n'est ce pas un leader en tant que
tel parce que c'est une insulte c'est
une provocation gratuite et est votée
par régis le jeune ne partait pas dans
ce schéma là pour provoquer ou insulté
la police où nous sommes là pour faire
respecter les règles la loi et ils iront
jusqu'au bout et ne fléchira pas de vent
devant des personnes aussi abjecte que
ce monsieur effectivement jérôme
rodriguez qui a traité certains d'entre
eux la police de bande de nazes il est
au coeur de cette nouvelle polémique 1
sur les réseaux sociaux après ce tweet
invectivant voilà vos collègues
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur à un porté plainte je vous
propose de l'écouter on va écouter
jérôme rodriguez un instant vas-y vous
irez ouvrir le camp de concentration
disponibles au nord-est de paris celui
que vous tentez de cacher aux médias et
voilà c'était donc le som ii de jérôme
rodriguez
vous avez déjà entendu gérald darmanin
qui porte plainte c'est un minimum pour
vous bruno bartocetti c'est au minimum
réaction immédiate de la part de notre
ministre j'espère que la justice va
sanctionner sévèrement parce que ne peut
pas accepter aujourd'hui dans une
république
saleh dans les rangs de la police vous
avez des vous avez des policiers qui ont
dès qu'ils sont petits fils ou fils de
déportés de résistance des juifs parmi
nous comment on peut accepter une telle
vocation ce n'est même pas une
provocation c'est même pas une insulte
c'est pire que ça je salue vinci jeu
si je peux le faire je salue les propos
de jean-marie bigard à l'instant et je
suis convaincu que les gilets jaunes
dans l'ensemble condamne jérôme de
rodrigues en tout cas je l'espère et
même si on peut regretter son parcours
ont cédé gilet jaune puisqu'il a été
victime d'une défense j'insiste bien
méritée tant de la part des policiers
sans viser son avis ce n'est pas parce
qu'il a été bien c'est qu'il doit
s'autoriser à insulter l'institution a
insulté les policiers comme il a fait ça
va même plus loin qu'une insulte c'est
une c'est vraiment que j'ai envie de
calais qualifiés ceux ci de crime moral
vous voyez c'est grave de tenir ce genre
de propos
et ça ça lui le mouvement des gilet
jaune vous savez que ce soit 68 1995
1984 c'était sur les écoles privées vous
aviez deux millions de personnes dans la
rue est ce qu'ils croient obtenant ce
genre de propos qui va rassembler du
monde autour de lui c'est impossible
la france est une est une deux pays
républicain respectueux de ses règles et
on a trop souffert pour entendre parler
de certaines divisions de l'assaut alors
c'est vrai que les propos sont sans fard
mono bartocetti il n'empêche qu'on se
doit de rappeler que jérôme rodriguez a
tout de même perdu un oeil lors d'une
manifestation après avoir été visé par
un flash-ball à défaut évidemment de
cautionner ces propos est-ce que vous
pouvez comprendre une forme de colère
chez une partie des gilet jaune dont
d'ailleurs jérôme rodriguez qui a été
blessé à vis des pc mais nous n'avons
pas visé le policier lorsqu'il utilise
son show elle bdc son lanceur de balles
de défense ne vise pas un oeil c'est
impossible c'est un peu comme un bras
arraché on ne le dit pas policiers sur
une manifestation pour arracher le bras
des et des manifestants lorsqu'on envoie
une grenade
simplement c'est pour écarter justement
les casseurs des manifestants parce
qu'on rejette des manifestants imputent
à des pseudo manifestants violents et
pour se défendre
on va pas me chercher des cas isolés je
vous parle de manière générale lorsque
vous avez aujourd'hui dans nos rangs
depuis le policier blessé je vous dis
bien de devenir policier blessé
seulement dans les manifestations de
gilet jaune alors qu'on a des casques et
des boucliers
c'est qu'on est visé avec des boules de
pétanque avec des projectiles qui
pourrait nous tuer si on n'avait pas
cessé de venir
on utiliserait notre arme de service en
matière légitime défense on ne pouvait
pas nous le reprocher donc aujourd'hui
si on doit retenir plus loin que des
blessures on doit retenir qu'on a aux
deux familles endeuillées aujourd'hui
c'était au début des mouvements de
jeunes pourquoi parce que les
manifestations étaient anarchique non
encadrés la violence ne s'exerce pas de
la part de la police
ils ont recentré le débat il ne faut pas
se tromper de cible
on il a sécurisé d'un manifestant et on
a des casseurs et bien au milieu qui
provoque qui vont jusqu'à vouloir tuer
du policier c'est ça la réalité ils
viennent pour tuer des policiers
ils ne viennent pas pour revendiquer
aujourd'hui nouveau ses dessins et ses
cibles ou autre chose puisque quand on
leur demande quel est le message
principal c'est de de parler de
désobéissance et d'aller écouter les
files devant les commissariats
voilà mon objectif je vous interromps
parce que linda bigot mieux vaut tard
que jamais on ait eu un petit souci
technique gilet jaune à nous avons je
crois pour ce qui était initialement un
débat ce sont les aléas du direct linda
bigot j'imagine que vous avez écouté
bruno bartocetti on évoque évidemment
cette affaire avec jérôme rodriguez qui
a eu des mots évidemment très dur bande
de nazis en qualifiant les les policiers
bruno bartocetti voilà qui se défendent
et voilà de ces violences policières
présumées en disant que souvent voilà
c'était une réponse à des attaques de la
part d'eads et gillet jose en faisant
référence notamment à la perte de l'oeil
de jérôme rodriguez
on parlait aussi de ces nouvelles
tensions qui sont craintes
pour les nouvelles manifestations à
partir de samedi vous les craignez vous
aussi ces tensions avec la police tout
d'abord je vais répondre à monsieur
bartoli c'est ça bonsoir manager parce
que j'ai bart aussi est-il pardon
excusez moi j'ai un peu suivi
là on a eu des problèmes techniques donc
j'ai un peu suivi ce que vous avez dit
depuis tout à l'heure une chose est sûre
c'est que monsieur jérôme rodriguez par
lens pour nous prendre ça c'est une
chose
par contre ce que j'apprécie moi c'est
quand que vous essayez de généraliser et
de stigmatiser absolument et gilet jaune
en pas en parlant de nous comme étant
des violents le noir il s'est mal
terminée monsieur jérôme rodriguez a
peut-être parlé sous le coup de
l'émotion parce qu'il s'est senti
attaqué sert personnellement par l'anrt
ayant mon nom je ne cautionne pas ces
propos je pense qu'il aurait peut-être
dû développer autrement puisqu'il subit
des attaques sur les réseaux sociaux
en attendant faut pas oublier que sur
rodriguez et quand même un épargner sur
30 ont été épargnés d'autres personnes
oui été mutilés n'oublions pas un de vos
confrères syndicaliste qui s'est
ouvertement moqué d'un jeune homme
sébastien mallet qui a perdu la main
alors vous parlez d'armement que vous
utilisez ceci cela ceci c'est là mais en
attendant nous n'essayons pas de
détourner l'attention
les armements que vous utilisez sondés
sont qualifiés d armement de guerre
cela a mutilé à épargner des personnes
sans compter des violences à outrance
des pacifistes ont été martyrisés
notamment je parle à mélanie je pense à
mélanie menadi qui a pris un coup de
matraque
derrière la tête qui en gardent des
séquelles parlons aussi de l'assaut de
cette unité de crs qui est entré dans le
burger king et matraques et des gilets
jaunes pacifistes en occurrence vous ne
vous êtes pas attaqué à des soi disant
casseurs mais bel et bien des pacifistes
monsieur certes ce qui a été tenu dans
les réseaux sociaux n'est pas cautionner
bhl et cela n'engage que monsieur
monsieur rodriguez mais vous ne pouvez
pas généraliser stigmatiser encore plus
le mouvement des gilets jaunes en dix
ans que vous craignez des violences à
venir
on ne connaît pas l'avenir on ne connaît
pas l'avenir bruno ben jassem vôtre
votre réponse on ne va pas
malheureusement pouvoir rester trop
longtemps puisque on arrivait à la fin
du débat à pardonner nous une bigot
votre réponse ou de même voilà ces
propos alors oui d'abord jeu elle a
répondu dans les clous de questions
j'insiste sur le fait que nous sommes
notre organisation syndicale à avoir été
les premiers à se tenir la tête
j'insiste bien lorsqu'il y avait 4 et
précise au lait très très isolée deux
flics qui ont dérapé
ces derniers ont fait l'objet d'une
enquête igpn et ont été sanctionnés donc
moi ce que je reproche c'est qu'on
remette en cause l'institution assez
combien je continue d'année pour des
propos important a dit mme urban shinzo
jsk comme gilet jaune pour le moment
pour moi et sur des voies réputation de
ma passion des petits bars
lorsqu un flic arrivé le matin pour
prendre son service ce n'est pas
beaucoup
merci à tous les deux merci à tous les
enfants sont tous la qualité du son est
extrêmement mauvaise inda bigot si on
policière pardon wind anigo bruno
bartocetti merci à vous en tout cas pour
ce 2 me face à face on va dire en tout
cas d'avoir accepté cette contradiction